yo what's up this is drewski this is red
flags and we about to get into it your
day doesn't like wearing sandals oh man
get out of here what are you doing Mama
it's all aware baby your day pulls out a
mini flosser at dinner oh I love that
because more people need to floss your
breath smells like
I preached that a lot you know people
don't know your gums got to stay healthy
for your breath to smell good so like I
said your breath smells like you're
gonna make you smile get some flaws your
Tate orders everything with the side of
ketchup
shooting nasty nasty I Loki like that so
I'm in the middle
is he nasty though you nasty but I like
that I like that your date says their ex
is crazy
that's actually a green one not a lot
and it's a reason why the brothers out
there that got them crazy ones or didn't
dealt with the you know I don't know
what that leading to
[Music]